dire très chiant c'est surtout je crois
que c'est les femmes
beaucoup de femmes sont très chiante oui
bah le plus chiant je ne sais pas
puisque je ne les pratiquent pas moi
c'est ne pas livrer truc que je ne pense
pas vraiment contre je lui ai envoyé une
chanson quand il ya eu le problème dit
on m'a le cyclone
je lui ai envoyé une chanson mais cette
chanson là elle m'a dit pourquoi ferions
nous pas un featuring et je lui dis non
c'est un featuring ne m'intéresse pas je
veux faire un vrai duo et j'avais déjà
cette chanson-là qui qui date de 30 ans
eh ben c'est avant de partir c'est son
gros tube inséré a été disque de platine
je crois avec ça c'est une chanson la
mélodie est réparable